-My first guest
is an Emmy-nominated actor
and comedian who stars
in the new movie --
stars, steals,
whatever you want to say --
the new movie
"Coming 2 America,"
which begins streaming on
Amazon Prime Video this Friday.
Amazon Prime Video, get ready.
It is going to break in half.
Here she is, Leslie Jones!
Leslie, ah, look at you.
I'm so happy to see you.
-Hey!
-Hey, buddy.
-Hey, Jimmy!
Hey, New York!
-[ Laughs ]
I'm so happy you're here.
I was just talking about you
with Queen Latifah last week.
Oh, my God. I love her.
-We were talking about
how much we love
when you live-tweet
her show "The Equalizer."
-I love her.
-I love anytime
you live-tweet anything.
And, you know, we've --
I've shown clips of "Below
Deck," I think me and you love.
-Oh.
-I showed --
But, dude, when you were
live-tweeting the news coverage
of the election,
people loved it, especially --
You were commenting
on the guest backgrounds.
And --
-It was a accident.
It was a accident.
It happened by accident.
I think I was watching it,
and I was like, "I don't think
these people are aware
of the stuff
that's behind them."
So I thought that -- You know,
crowd work is my thing.
I was like,
"Oh, this is too fun."
And it just became a thing.
-We put together some highlights
of your commentaries.
Check this out.
-Yes, Miss Claire
with the black --
I don't think
that's a turtleneck.
That's some kind of ninja suit.
He look like...
like he wake up reading books.
We got a clean kitchen?
This is where the [bleep]
we doing the news.
Rebecca, what do you do
for a living?
If that's New York, bitch,
you paying some money.
Aah! Steve!
Is he writing on the board?
[ Laughing ] I love this dude!
[ Both laugh ]
-"He's writing on the board.
Ha, ha. I love this dude."
-Yo, you can't understand
the love that I felt
for Steve Kornacki.
So, let me explain something,
what was happening.
I was watching
these news channels.
But I didn't like the way
they was covering the election.
They was walking
across the floor
like it was a damn NBA final.
No!
I'm not supposed to see
Wolf Blitzer's shoes!
No!
I say no!
And if they --
And then they was walking
like they knew everything,
and they wasn't doing nothing
but saying the same thing --
just rubbing they hands
and, like, "Well, what do we got
across here?"
Then take a whole long shot
where they walk across.
I wanted to run on there
and punch them in the face,
like stop!
But then I switched
over to MSNBC,
and there was a nerd
of all calibers.
-[ Laughs ]
-He was dressed
for the occasion.
He was stressed out.
He was wrinkled.
He was "dis-shuffled."
He was concerned.
You could tell that that man
had washed up in the wash room.
You know how you see them scenes
in the news movies,
and they'll be like
"Come on, Joyce, you got to
get me the information!"
That's Steve Kornacki.
-Yes, yes, yes. He's real.
-I knew -- I knew
that something was gon' happen
when that boy pulled out
that calculator.
I said, "Look here.
Look here!
I'm gon' find. out.
what's. going. on."
-[ Laughs ]
-Steve Kornacki,
you are my snacky.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Both laugh ]
-I --
I heard that you got mad at him
when he was
going on other things.
He was doing other stuff.
You go, "Stop it."
They're taking him from you.
-Wha--
Why is you passing Steve around
like a joint?
He's not a joint.
He is a valuable "statician."
It's just, you can't be
putting him on --
He doing football stats.
I bet you
Steve was dying inside,
using them numbers
for that mess!
-[ Laughs ]
I want to talk to you --
I want to talk to you about
"Coming 2 America," the sequel.
-"Coming 2."
-Leslie, let me
tell you something.
I have known you for years now.
I've seen you destroy.
I've seen -- I've worked
with you in sketches.
I've seen you on-stage.
You're already
in legendary status.
-Aww, that's so sweet.
-This movie put you
in a whole new thing
that I don't even know
if you're ready for this thing,
'cause honestly,
it was laugh-out-loud,
screaming-laughing funny for me.
I go, "What is going on?
They let her be --
They let her
just go off and play."
We've had Eddie on.
We've had everyone
from the movie on,
and they all bring it up.
I bring --
I'm about to bring it up.
They're like,
"No, no, stop. Leslie."
I go, "Yes."
So, basically, am I allowed to
say who you play in the movie?
'Cause I'm not sure
what I can --
-I think so. I'm his baby mama.
-There you go. So, he has a son.
-Basically. Basically.
-The Prince has a son.
-Wow.
-By a real chick,
like one of them real chicks.
Like, yeah. You know?
Shari wasn't the only one
he hit in Queens, you know?
-How was Eddie
to do the scenes with?
Was he fun?
-It was funny, because every
time he would walk on-set,
it's just very surreal,
because you know I'm a comedian.
And Eddie is who, you know,
like, after Richard Pryor,
I was like, "Oh, my God.
There's a guy who can perform
like Richard Pryor."
That's literally
what I thought of Eddie Murphy
when I first saw him.
I was like, "Oh, my God.
There's somebody
as funny as Richard Pryor?"
-Yeah.
-And just to be on a set
with somebody like that,
and he's just, like, Eddie,
you know?
He's just walking through,
and you're like, "Yeah. Yeah.
I honestly love you."
-Do you remember the first time
when he laughed at you?
Laughed with you?
-Actually, Eddie saw me
at the Laugh Factory
long, long, long
before "SNL" and all of that.
-Really?
-So, he saw me
at the Laugh Factory.
And Pooky, the dude
that was running the room --
There's always a dude
named Pooky running the room.
And he said, "Hey,
Eddie wants to meet you."
And I went over to the side,
and I was like,
"Oh, my God. Eddie Murphy."
And he was like,
"Oh, my God. You were so funny."
And I said, "Eddie --"
I think -- I asked him
the dumbest question.
I was like, "Eddie, if you was
a comic like in this time,
would you do BET ComicView?"
And he was like, "Yeah.
Definitely."
[ Laughs ]
And I was like, "Okay."
-Wow.
-And I was like --
I went home, and I was like,
"Anything. You could have
asked him anything!
And that's what you asked him?"
It was --
And then I got to see him again,
you know, through "SNL"
and all of that.
But, you know --
-This is going to --
Seriously, I think
it's going to break Amazon.
They better be ready for this,
'cause it's happening on Friday.
-I hope so.
-Everyone in the world
is talking about this movie.
I want to show a clip.
Here's the great Leslie Jones
in "Coming 2 America."
Take a look at this.
-[ Laughing ] Ooh! What?!
-Hashtag family.
-That's the last surprise.
-Hey! What's up, y'all?
-Hi. What's up, fam?
I'm gon' hug you
'cause I'm a hugger.
Hey, Queen.
I'm sorry I slept with your man.
-What is going on here?
-Oh, children.
Children, I would love
for you to meet your brother.
-And my name is Mary.
How you doing?
Just call me your second mom.
-But you really
don't have to, girls.
-I mean, but you should, though,
'cause I kind of am.
-Well, look at us, just one
big, happy, Zamundan-American,
aristocratic blended family.
-Ah, just like the Kardashians!
[ Chuckles ]
-Leslie Jones!
"Coming 2 America"
will be streaming on
Amazon Prime Video this Friday.